[Music]
we even have a couple of Herbie's one
from her be fully loaded which was the
Lindsay Lohan moon that when I bet
smells like vomit Shane I'm Matty Andrea
and this is car collectors hi I'm Chris
Brown welcome to the Petersen Automotive
Museum I'm gonna take you around and
show you the world's best cars come with
me the vault is the underground storage
area at the Petersen Automotive Museum
for all the vehicles that aren't part of
an exhibit upstairs in the public areas
for nearly 20 years the vault was a
space that everybody knew about but
nobody knew how to get down here we have
every genre you can think of from
alternative power to Hollywood from
political cars to pre-war cars muscle
cars hot rods cars of the stars
including the Batmobile who has a
Batmobile you name it we probably have
at least one here Chris here we are in
the vault of the Petersen museum I've
never been down I've been to the museum
a hundred times I've never seen this
place before
so you're really down here for a
behind-the-scenes tour the Petersen well
let's start that and here this mammoth
of a car this thing is amazing
tell me about what this is we call it
the round or rolls right what's it
really hot it's in a 1925 / 34
rolls-royce phantom one aerodynamic
coupe and you call it the round door
rolls for this obvious reason the
rolls-royce that are on the road today
they have this huge massive grill put it
it pales by comparison to this thing
yeah not only is it huge but it's fake
the real grill is actually behind this
so this is just ready to be a facade
this is just this is just dressing it's
all showmanship as cool as this thing is
I'm a sucker for performance cars Chris
now we have original Ford gt40 yep and
then the late model Ford GT but this car
is different Ford wanted to kick
Ferraris but Lamaze so they went and
spent a whole bunch of money on
developing this car they needed to make
a handful of them to sell the public
this is the only one that was never
turned into a race car so it's always
been a street this 101 basically exactly
now
Ford came out with the Ford GT sort of
the modern-day version of that tell me
something about this car they redesigned
the car but kept all the original
styling cues they would design this car
during Ford's 100th anniversary so
Camilla will actually put a 1 a 0 and a
0 in the headlight Chris I'm a fan of
Jaguar and tucked in the back corner of
the vault is this amazing xkss they only
made 16 of these before the factory
burned to the ground so it's a very rare
car but what makes this really unique is
who owned it it was Steve McQueen the
king of cool he almost lost his license
in fact there was a police chief who
offered any of his officers a steak
dinner if they could catch McQueen drive
in the xkss
Chris the vault is absolutely amazing
what I love about it that's a little bit
different than upstairs is you can get
right up close with these cars thank you
so much for letting us down here I've
always wanted to come check out the
vault and to you guys please subscribe
to GQ and tell us what you want to see
here on car collectors
you